some political watchers are saying this
could be the nastiest most negative
election season of all time this
campaign season seems like candidates
have taken dirty to a whole new level
when London starts shouting and
politicians start calling each other's
names it can seem like a return to
civility is not possible
like the very idea is a relic of some
bygone bygone era John Adams he's a
blind bald crippled toothless man who
wants to start a war with France while
he's not busy importing mistresses from
Europe he's trying to marry one of his
sons to a daughter of King George
haven't we had enough monarchy in
America
I'm Thomas Jefferson and I approve this
message because John Adams is a hideous
hermaphroditical character with neither
the force and firmness of a man with a
gentleness and sensibility of a woman if
Thomas Jefferson wins murder robbery
rape adultery and incest will be openly
taught and practiced the air will be
rent with the cries of the distressed
the soil will be soaked with blood and
the nation black with crimes are you
prepared to see your dwellings in flames
female chastity violated children
writhing on a pike I'm John Adams and I
approve this message because Jefferson
is the son of a half-breed Indian [ __ ]
raised on hoecakes
and Hamilton is a Creole bastard brat of
a scotch peddler the nastiest most
negative election he's had taken dirty
to a whole new can seem like a return to
civility is not possible